6 mars 2003 à 13h45 les enquêteurs et
Laurent Gauvin quittent la maison
d'arrêt à bord d'un convoi de la police
judiciaire une certaine tension règne
dans la voiture les policiers espèrent
que le jeune homme va leur livrer enfin
la conclusion de l'affaire Laurent
Gauvin fait arrêter les enquêteurs dans
un virage près d'un talus
et leur indique le chemin d'un petit
bois
il va nous conduire dans les bois
et va nous dire c'est là tout simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Nice sur la Côte d'Azur le 11 mars 2002
nous sommes sur les hauteurs de la ville
sur la colline de Gairaut au lieu-dit de
l'air Saint Michel
des miaulements incessants se font
entendre
ils proviennent de cette maison
c'est miaulement durent depuis quelques
heures et les voisins commencent à
s'inquiéter
le voisin lorsqu'ils entendent ce chat
miauler enfin c'est des hurlements qui
qu'ils entendent ils pensent qu'il y a
un problème c'était c'est jamais arrivé
donc il se rendent sur place et
découvre qu'il y a personne les
propriétaires du chat Francine Véran
Raspini 72 ans et son fils Marc 48 ans
semble absent depuis quelques jours ce
simple fait suffit à inquiéter leurs
voisins
madame Raspini ne s'absente pas de la
propriété son fils Marc descend
quelquefois en ville
de temps en temps Madame Raspini la
compagne mais très exceptionnellement
elle est présente sur la propriété cette
absence inhabituelle fait beaucoup
parler car les raspinis ne sont pas
n'importe qui il possède quatre hectares
de terrain sur la colline de Gairaut il
loue de petites parcelles à une
vingtaine de personnes
dans ces potagers dans ses jardins il y
a des jardiniers qui sont là depuis plus
de 20 ans il y a des habitués qui
d'ailleurs font certains font des
fleuves on est très jolies jardins ils
sont presque comme chez eux on va dire
et puis régulièrement il voit même le
reste midi pour l'encaissement ou même
pour discuter du beau temps enfin de
tous et de rien quoi il y a quand même
tout le monde se connaît un petit peu
quand même
et comme personne n'a vu les race
pignies depuis 5 jours l'une de leurs
locataires craint qu'il ne soit arrivé
quelque chose
[Musique]
elle décide d'appeler les pompiers
les pompiers de la caserne de Nice
arrivent sur les lieux vers 9h30 les
portes de la maison sont fermées mais
ils accèdent à l'intérieur par une
fenêtre entrouverte
leur priorité c'est bien sûr de vérifier
si l'un ou l'autre ne sont pas présents
dans la dans le logement s'ils ne sont
pas évanouis ou si s'ils sont décédés
mais c'est leur priorité
vérification au fait les raspillies ne
se trouvent pas dans la propriété les
pompiers s'en vont
toujours inquiets la voisine des raspi
prévient alors un cousin de Francine
Lazare Lorenzi qui vit à Nice
on a essayé de porter plainte mais
la police nous a dit vous savez ils sont
majeurs ils font ce qu'ils veulent ils
peuvent très bien
être en voyage ou quoi
la police lance tout de même une Rif une
recherche dans l'intérêt des familles
elle vérifie dans les fichiers
administratifs à sa disposition que les
raspinis n'ont pas été signalés et
Raspini ne laisse aucune trace la rive
ne donne rien la vérification qui est
faite par exemple auprès des hôpitaux ne
donnent rien les raspinines sont
hospitalisés les morgues n'ont plus
aucun corps correspondant au Raspini
n'est retrouvé
il n'y a aucune trace de aucun fichier
qui est consulté où sont passés les
raspinis leur est-il arrivé quelque
chose l'affaire va rebondir 10 jours
plus tard lorsque l'on va retrouver la
voiture de Marc Raspini
25 mars 2002 parc de l'Arenas dans le
quartier Ouest de NICE le gardien du
parking est perplexe cela fait près de
15 jours qu'un véhicule une Renault 11
est garéla et il y en a déjà pour près
de 350 euros de stationnement
le gardien à la surprise de constater
qu'en plus les portes ne sont pas
verrouillées et ce n'est pas tout c'est
inquiétant suspect parce que les clés se
trouvent dans le vide poche grâce à la
plaque d'immatriculation les policiers
identifient le véhicule il appartient à
Marc Raspini alors pourquoi l'homme
a-t-il laissé sa voiture ici les
policiers vont s'intéresser aux environs
du parking et ce ne sont pas les pistes
qui manquent
première piste l'aéroport de Nice Côte
d'Azur le parking de l'Arena s'est situé
à quelques centaines de mètres seulement
et les Niçois qui prennent l'avion ils
laissent volontiers leur véhicule c'est
un quartier où on peut abandonner la
voiture pour partir rejoindre l'avion il
est vrai que Francine et Marc Raspini
s'offraient parfois des petits voyages
ensemble
[Musique]
trois quatre jours à l'Autriche en
Turquie
mais je peux pas très loin quand même
mais s'ils étaient partis en vacances
les raspinis auraient au moins prévenu
leurs proches et de toute façon leur nom
ne figure sur aucun volcan et
vérifications bien sûr sont faites à ce
niveau-là dans dans les fichiers et les
Raspini n'ont pas pris l'avion
les enquêteurs vont alors s'intéresser à
une deuxième piste alors ce parking a
été un parking qui a la particularité
d'être fréquenté par des prostituées qui
y font des passes
or certains témoignages ont permis de le
vérifier Marc Raspini était un grand
amateur de prostituées c'était un bon
client et un bon payeur il payait
d'ailleurs en liquide avec l'argent des
loyers qui passaient en partie là dedans
l'enquête va d'ailleurs permettre de
découvrir que le quadragénaire amené
parfois l'une de ces jeunes femmes sur
la propriété familiale
donc il va au quartier de l'Arenas ou
carrément il en fait venir et la
dérégulière qui fait venir dans la
maison et je crois même qu'il s'est même
attaché à l'une d'elles il a fait venir
régulièrement d'ailleurs
Marc Raspini aurait-il fui avec cette
femme ou bien ce serait-il fait
dépouiller les enquêteurs vont chercher
à identifier la jeune prostituée en
question
nous découvrons une prostituée bulgare
Katia qui a eu des relations un petit
peu plus suivies avec Marc Raspini elle
est montée à la propriété c'était une
prostituée qui sur les réseaux locaux en
fait vient travailler en meublé trois
mois plus tard revient trois mois en
fait pour rester dans le cadre des visas
mais en étudiant les fichiers de
l'immigration les enquêteurs constatent
que la dénommée Katia ne se trouvait pas
en France au moment des faits faute
d'indice les hommes de la PJ décide
alors de laisser de côté le parking de
l'Arenas et de se concentrer sur le
domicile des deux disparus
[Musique]
27 mars 2002 sur la colline de Gairaut
deux jours après la découverte de la
voiture les enquêteurs décident de
perquisitionner la propriété des Raspini
et la première surprise la porte
d'entrée de la maison est fermée mais
pas verrouillé
[Musique]
en arrivant sur la propriété nous allons
grâce au serruriers requis par nos soins
ouvrir la porte
on nous apercevons que la porte est
claquée qu'elle est pas plus fermée que
ça quant à l'intérieur de la maison il
se trouve dans un état invraisemblable
[Musique]
nous découvrons en rentrant dans la
maison un certain désordre
c'est une maison qui est mal tenue il
n'y a pas eu de travaux depuis des
décennies
les affaires traînent il y a cette
accumulation de sa plastique cette
accumulation de déchets divers c'était
un petit peu bohème
et bon la police cherche partout
il y avait des tiroirs ouverts
mais à certains détails les enquêteurs
ont le sentiment que les raspi ont
quitté les lieux dans l'urgence
dans la maison on est très étonné
pourquoi parce qu'on se rend compte que
manifestement il y a eu un départ
précipité et nous pouvons relever de
suite des éléments qui sont surprenants
dans la cuisine la vaisselle sale est au
milieu de l'évier les affaires semblent
on est parti d'un coup la poubelle n'est
pas vidée les brosses à dents sont
présentes dans la salle de bain
l'espace de vie semble s'être arrêté
brutalement
et au milieu des ordures et de la
vaisselle sale les enquêteurs vont
découvrir leur premier indice un indice
qui ne fait pas plus de quelques
centimètres nous remarquons
immédiatement un détail qui
peut paraître anodin dans l'espèce de
Capharnaüm qui n'est pas vraiment très
ordonné mais il y a un mégot
or les enquêteurs le savent ni Francine
Raspini ni son fils Marc ne sont fumeurs
ce mégot pourrait-il mener un suspect
à l'aide du technicien de Polytechnique
et scientifique qui nous accompagnent
nous prélevons le mégot c'est un premier
indice
[Musique]
dans un placard un policier va faire une
autre découverte
ce qui attire notre attention dans cette
affaire là particulièrement c'est la
présence
d'une boîte
d'ordinateur portable
d'après la facture marque Raspini a
acheté cet ordinateur très récemment
seulement dans l'appartement pas de
trace de l'appareil
et l'ordinateur portable n'est pas sur
place
il n'est pas retrouvé et donc on se pose
la question de savoir pourquoi cet
ordinateur n'est pas n'est pas là une
porte facile à ouvrir un mégot suspect
et un ordinateur absent la maison des
raspinis aurait-elle été visité par des
intrus la perquisition se poursuit à
l'extérieur de la maison et là encore
les policiers vont faire une découverte
surprenante
[Musique]
nous trouvons dans la boîte aux lettres
des chèques des petits papiers avec des
enveloppes avec du liquide c'est
surprenant et en fait on nous expliquera
que c'est la gestion des lopains de
terre la gestion des cabanons la gestion
des garages qui est géré comme ça par
Madame Raspini c'est-à-dire que Ben en
liquide on met l'argent dans une
enveloppe on met les initiales et
l'enveloppe dans la boîte aux lettres
[Musique]
pourquoi madame Raspini n'a-t-elle pas
ramassé ses loyers à en croire sa
réputation elle n'était pas du genre à
laisser traîner l'argent
[Musique]
décrite par les voisins comme une femme
peintre très très économe qui ne dépense
pas grand chose une fois elle m'a dit
mais pourquoi tu as acheté une voiture
neuve mais je dis parce que je m'en fais
parce que je monte en Belgique je monte
à Noël je veux pas
une casserole et oh mais c'est de
l'argent de la fille et elle m'avait dit
des gens comme ça voilà Francine race
Pini était très à cheval et adopté une
gestion particulièrement rigoureuse de
ces de ces petits repas de terre qu'elle
louait et donc il était aussi anormal
dans le cas d'espèces de trouver un peu
d'argent dans la boîte aux lettres ça
rajoutait à l'inquiétude des uns et des
autres les enquêteurs comprennent que
Francine Raspini n'aurait jamais laissé
ainsi ses loyers traîner dans sa boîte
une question se pose donc la vieille
dame et son fils ont-ils été les
victimes d'un kidnapping au pire d'un
meurtre
[Musique]
dès le lendemain les policiers se
lancent dans une tâche ardu essayez de
cerner le mode de vie de Madame Raspini
et de son fils
on essaye d'identifier tous les toutes
les personnes susceptibles d'avoir un
contact une relation avec les raspi et
dès les premières rencontres auprès des
locataires de Madame Raspini il se
rendent compte que la vieille dame
n'était pas très sociable
[Musique]
elle n'allait pas souvent au restaurant
elle ne sortait pas souvent donc
elle faisait une vie un peu à part
au lycée de son mari elle est restée la
propriété apérité son fils
âgé de 48 ans on nous dira qu'il souffre
de troubles psychiatriques et rester sur
la propriété
dans cette maison les rôles sont bien
définis madame Raspini est une femme de
caractère qui décide de tout et Marc son
fils appliqua la lettre ses décisions je
le recouvrement des créances des loyers
il fait le garde du corps il fait le
méchant quand quand les loyers rentrent
pas assez vite il n'est pas marié il
n'est pas en relation avec
un copain ou une copine il n'a pas
d'amis il n'a que sa maman sa vieille
maman de 72 ans avec laquelle il vit
retirer comme un reclus
c'est très bizarre tout ça la seule
source de revenus des Raspini ce sont
les locations de leurs propriétés
immobilières les parcelles de la colline
de Gairaut et quelques appartements dans
la ville de Nice leur rapporte beaucoup
d'argent les raspiniers ont
un patrimoine assez conséquent d'abord
leur maison un dont ils sont
propriétaires et ensuite ils ont des
loyers qui
en ville des appartements mais surtout
les parcelles de terrain qui louent à
des jardiniers
en espèces et tout ça ça doit faire dans
les dans les dix mille euros par mois
voire plus et ce qui est surprenant
c'est que ces 10000 euros par mois les
raspinis ne les plaçaient jamais à la
banque ils avaient décidé de garder leur
argent chez eux en liquide depuis un
incident il y a quelques années avec
l'administration des impôts
suite au versement en liquide de leur
argent en quantité non négligeable sur
leur compte bancaire le fisc que les
avait redressés et visiblement depuis le
redressement fiscal il ne déposait plus
l'argent
doute
les espèces quand elle
ça se disait que les que les les
raspinis vérans avaient à gauche
et je pense que ça a pu susciter des
convoitises
mais ce magot ces grosses sommes
d'argent en liquides les policiers n'en
n'ont pas trouvé la moindre trace lors
de la perquisition la thèse d'un vol ou
d'un crime crapuleux se précise d'autant
plus que les policiers vont découvrir
dans l'entourage des racines un homme
particulièrement suspect
les policiers s'intéressent de près au
locataire des raspignies sur ces quatre
hectares qui leur appartiennent évoluent
une population d'une vingtaine de
personnes
il y a des personnes un petit peu âgées
des jardiniers passionnés dans la
passion est devoir pousser les
faitvettes et les radis et puis il y a
des marginaux qui ont profité de ces
possibilités de cabanon pour pouvoir y
habiter pratiquement à l'année dans un
confort relatif on a l'électricité on a
l'eau or parmi les locataires de la
colline de Gairaut il y a un individu
qui lui aussi a disparu depuis quelques
jours et on s'aperçoit
qu'un jardinier
d'origine maghrébine a disparu c'est de
nommer Kamel qui n'a pas toujours eu des
rapports très très facile et éclairage
fini ou dont on dit qu'il aurait eu des
rapports un peu houleux parfois l'homme
s'appelle Kamel knini cela fait 20 ans
qu'il travaille au service de Francine
Raspini il est à la fois son jardinier
et son homme à tout faire
pourquoi a-t-il disparu une dispute
aurait-elle éclatée pourrait-il être
impliqué dans la disparition des
raspinis grâce à son numéro de téléphone
portable les enquêteurs vont facilement
localiser le jardinier
et surprise il se trouve à seulement 10
km de la dans le petit village
d'Aspremont dans l'arrière-pays niçois
les policiers se rendent aussitôt sur
place et l'interpelle sans difficulté
nous retrouvons Kamel qui s'est réfugiée
chez des amis et en fait nous allons
retrouver un ouvrier agricole apeuré
interrogé par les policiers Kamel
explique que s'il se cache depuis
quelques jours c'est parce qu'il n'a pas
de papier en règle il avait simplement
peur d'être expulsé en fait Kamel a
disparu non pas parce qu'il a quelque
chose à se reprocher mais parce que il
est sans papier et donc
je pense qu'il a pas trop envie de se
faire attraper mais dans sa déposition
Kamel aiguille les policiers vers un
autre locataire des Raspini
le jardinier va nous donner des éléments
très intéressants sur des comportements
qui l'a eu l'occasion de constater
lui-même de vivre
entre Francine Raspini et un locataire
de
ces lopin de terre en l'occurrence un
certain Philippe Leblanc ce Philippe
Leblanc est un homme d'une trentaine
d'années il vit sur une parcelle des
raspinis depuis seulement quelques mois
et il a apparemment causé beaucoup de
soucis
on va apprendre que cet individu alloué
pendant un certain temps
un petit un petit terrain qu'il avait un
chien et que ce chien a été source de
problème le roi de verre avait des
problèmes sur la propriété avec d'autres
personnes qui avaient des chiens il a
fallu le déplacer et puis un litige est
intervenu concernant le paiement de
l'électricité il est évident que la
répartition d'électricité était un petit
peu empirique sur la propriété et
monsieur Leblanc refusé de payer
[Musique]
le jardinier nous dit qu'il a été
menaçant qu'il a été le témoin de menace
envers madame Raspini
l'ennui c'est que le blanc ne vit plus
sur la propriété personne ne sait ce
qu'il est devenu depuis son départ
en revanche Kamel le jardinier a eu
plusieurs conversations téléphoniques
avec le blanc les jours précédents les
policiers identifient donc facilement
son numéro
et en vérifiant auprès de l'opérateur
téléphonique les policiers apprennent
que le numéro est enregistré sous un
autre nom celui de Philippe Dubois
s'agirait-il du vrai nom du suspect
le blanc alias Dubois l'homme possède
une double identité et il a menacé
Francine Raspini quelques jours avant sa
disparition il est donc le premier
suspect sérieux des enquêteurs
quelques jours plus tard un courrier
inattendu va leur apporter deux suspects
supplémentaires
[Musique]
5 avril 2002 cela va faire un mois que
les raspignan ont disparu ce matin les
hommes de la brigade criminelle de Nice
reçoivent une lettre qui va beaucoup les
intéresser
[Musique]
elle provient de la banque de Francis
Raspini deux individus ont essayé
d'encaisser des chèques signés par la
vieille dame
des chèques d'un montant
particulièrement élevé
la BNP qui est l'établissement qui gère
les comptes de Madame Raspini nous
signalera deux chèques importants 17 et
13 et 11000 euros par mesure de
précaution la banque a comparé la
signature des deux chèques avec un
exemplaire authentique de la signature
de Francine Raspini et cela saute aux
yeux les signatures d'échec sont de
mauvaises imitations
visiblement ce n'est pas l'écriture des
habituelles des raspinines et leur
signature et en plus il y a par mois un
problème sur le compte enfin en tout cas
la BNP a émet des doutes quant à la
validité de ses chèques
dans son courrier la banque a transmis
l'identité des individus qui ont déposé
les deux chèques volés
il s'agit de Patrick Gauvin 52 ans et de
son fils Laurent 22 ans
étrange coïncidence les deux hommes
habitent dans la cité des moulins un
quartier de Nice qui se trouve à deux
pas du parking de l'Arenas la même ou la
Renault 11 de Marc Raspini a été
retrouvée reste à comprendre quelles
sont les relations entre Patrick et
Laurent Gauvin et Philippe Dubois
nous allons tisser le réseau des
relations autour de le blanc et autour
des gens qui pour lesquels qui ont
encaissé l'échec à savoir les Gauvains
père et fils
les trois hommes sont aussitôt placés
sur écoute les enquêteurs vont constater
qu'ils se connaissent et se téléphone
régulièrement mais le trio est prudent
au téléphone aucune référence à France
ciné-marcraft Pini dans leur
conversation au bout de plusieurs jours
de surveillance les policiers commencent
à perdre espoir or il n'y a pas de temps
à perdre les raspinis sont peut-être
encore vivants détenus quelque part
alors pour pousser les suspects à la
faute les policiers vont leur tendre un
piège
samedi 13 avril 2002 ce jour-là un fait
divers fait la Une de Nice-Matin une
septua-généré son fils ont disparu en
page intérieure les portraits de
Francine Marc Raspini et ce que personne
ne cesse et que cette une a été préparée
en collaboration étroite avec la police
ce matin est contacté par la police
judiciaire en accord avec le parquet
pour lancer un appel à témoin
pour que la police puisse la justice
puisse mettre toutes les chances de leur
côté
d'abord le moindre indice susceptible de
permettre de retrouver cette mère et son
fils
le titre qui est décidé
sur le quotidien c'est mystérieuse
disparition sur les hauteurs de Guero
on fait paraître deux photos la photo de
Francis Raspini et celle de son fils
on va faire apparaître aussi un numéro
de téléphone qui est le numéro de
téléphone a appelé
pour l'appel à témoin
[Musique]
le but de se taper la témoin trouver des
gens qui éventuellement les aurait vus à
l'aéroport dans une gare dans une grande
surface dans un restaurant dans une
voiture
ou n'importe où ailleurs tous ces
éléments vont créer en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on espère à ce moment-là un choc un
choc psychologique dans l'esprit des
personnes que l'on suspecte
[Musique]
et cet objectif est atteint car le jour
même les écoutes téléphoniques
surprennent plusieurs conversations
paniquée entre les suspects
tout d'abord à 12h39
Patrick Gauvin qui semble avoir lu
l'article appelle son fils Laurent
[__] ça y est ils savent non
tu as pas vu le journal Le journal en
gros c'est marqué dedans mais en gros en
première page et tout
quelques minutes plus tard Laurent
prévient Philippe Dubois
[Musique]
prends le journal tu verras je te
conseille de le prendre c'est tout après
je passe te voir
à 14h49 Philippe Dubois rappelle Laurent
[__] c'est grave sérieux ça va tu
flippes pas au moins tu passes me voir
seul on discute
ils savent de quoi il parle ils savent
que la disparition des raspiniants c'est
pas un épiphénomène qui est sur
Nice-Matin pour rien ils nous verront ce
jour-là que ça dans Nice-Matin
pour la police judiciaire ces appels
confirment la complicité entre les trois
hommes une seule solution à présent pour
les faire parler les arrêter
le 18 avril 2002 à 9h du matin la police
fait une descente cité des moulins
Patrick Gauvin le père est arrêté et
placé en garde à vue
dans son appartement la police s'arrête
sans difficulté son fils Laurent
quand à Philippe Dubois le troisième
homme les policiers ne savent pas où il
se cache
[Musique]
mais dans les heures qui suivent les
écoutes téléphoniques captent un nouvel
appel entre lui et sa femme jeune Vienne
ce matin ils ont levé Patrick
et Laurent tous les deux et alors je le
sais maintenant je leur ai envoyé
l'avocate t'inquiète pas il y a pas à
s'inquiéter tu crois pour eux peut-être
pas pour moi t'inquiète pas non non il
balanceront jamais hein t'inquiète pas
je leur avais dit de pas mettre l'échec
à l'encaissement c'est con mais enfin
c'est leur problème
localiser grâce à son téléphone portable
Philippe Dubois est finalement arrêté
dans une station-service
[Musique]
l'homme est placé en garde à vue
les policiers se rendent ensuite à son
domicile pour une perquisition et ils
vont découvrir une pièce qui manquait à
leur puzzle
une opération importante parce qu'elle
va nous permettre rapidement en rentrant
chez lui de découvrir un ordinateur
portable dans une sacoche un ordinateur
portable qui correspond exactement à
celui qui a été volé chez Marc Raspini
que fait cet appareil chez Philippe
Dubois l'homme a une réponse toute
trouvée avant qu'on pose la moindre
question il aura ce cri du coeur c'est
l'ordinateur de marque c'est lui qui me
l'a donné et puis au fil de la
perquisition c'est sa mère je l'ai
acheté
mais il aura aucun doute sur la présence
et l'origine de cet ordinateur les
principaux suspects sont maintenant sous
les verrous les policiers ont peut-être
une chance de retrouver Francine Raspini
et son fils vivant
d'autant que certaines langues vont
finir par ce délier
la mystérieuse disparition d'une riche
septuagénaire et de son fils à Nice la
rentière et ce fils de 48 ans n'ont plus
donné signe de vie depuis le 10 mars
dernier trois hommes ont été mis en
examen et écroués pour enlèvement et
séquestration les enquêteurs penchent en
effet pour la piste criminelle le
lendemain de la triple arrestation
l'affaire raspigny fait la Une de
l'actualité nationale anis également on
ne parle que de ça le quotidien Nice
Matin publie un nouvel appel à témoin et
cette fois les noms des trois suspects
sont publiés du coup de nouveautés moins
vont se présenter spontanément à la
police judiciaire
ce qui concerne Patrick bovin qui se dit
totalement étranger à tout ça et bien on
va apprendre qu'il s'est vantait auprès
de deux connaissances au moins 3
d'ailleurs de ce que il avait
effectivement fait un projet avec des
amis pour faire un gros coup comme il le
disait un autre témoin spontané va faire
une déclaration encore plus accusatrice
j'ai croisé Patrick Gauvin un dimanche
soir extrêmement pâle il se vantait
d'avoir touché 17000 euros pour avoir
fumé une femme et son fils on sait à
partir de cet instant à ce moment là que
les raspignies sont morts qu'ils ont été
assassinés
la grande inconnue
pour nous à ce moment-là c'est où se
trouvent les corps immédiatement la
police fait fouiller la propriété des
raspinis mais le terrain est grand
quatre hectares et sa végétation est
propice à toutes les cachettes
il y a eu plusieurs battues organisées
dans la dans le domaine qui est quand
même énorme
il y a des il y a des jardiniers il y a
des jardins c'est vrai mais il y a aussi
des roseaux il y a des il y a de la
forêt
c'est très complexe il y avait là sur la
propriété suffisamment de possibilités
simplement déjà pour cacher les corps
alors le juge d'instruction va
interroger les trois suspects sans
relâche l'ennui c'est que leurs
explications sont totalement
incohérentes
Patrick Gauvin en ce qui concerne
l'origine du chèque donne différentes
explications
en particulier il va dire que
c'est le paiement de travaux qu'il a
effectué chez le Raspini mais en réalité
Patrick Gauvin va évoluer dans ses
déclarations il va mentir il va offrir
11 versions différentes au final les
Gauvains reconnaissent avoir organisé un
cambriolage pour voler le sac de
Francine en revanche il nie toute
violence et affirme qu'ils n'ont tué
personne quand a Philippe Dubois il
affirme qu'il est totalement étranger à
l'affaire et pour l'ordinateur portable
ce sont les Gauvains qui lui ont donné
comme l'affirme encore son avocat Maître
Baudoux
ma conviction est que Philippe Dubois
était peut-être resseller de ce qu'il
lui avait été présenté par les Gauvains
comme un cambriolage et dès lors ayant
connaissance de l'enquête ayant
connaissance de l'inquiétude des
Gauvains Philippe Dubois a pu
s'interroger sur l'origine de ce qui lui
avait été proposé par les Gauvains sont
pour autant avoir participé
effectivement au fait criminels pour
l'ordinateur il va nous dire que c'est
un cadeau et que il n'est pas allé le
chercher chez les raspinis puisque un
ordinateur a été récupéré et toutes tout
explication qui chaque fois se termine
par mais de toute façon moi mon rôle est
un rôle tout à fait mineur je n'ai rien
demandé à personne et je n'y suis
véritablement pour pas grand chose
peut-être un receleur mais pas plus les
enquêteurs ne sont pas convaincus à
leurs yeux Philippe du bois n'est pas un
simple receleur bien au contraire il est
le cerveau de la bande Philippe Dubois
est un manipulateur un homme brillant
il a un côté violent et
il a forcément une emprise
intellectuelle sur les Gauvains qui sont
beaucoup plus simple
[Musique]
il est pas non plus à passer de voyou
ça jamais été un type du Grand monétisme
en revanche on sent que c'est un gars
costaud moralement c'est quelqu'un qui
est plutôt sur le registre de la
séduction dans un premier temps en tout
cas et puis lorsqu'il n'a pas gain de
cause ou lorsqu'il n'aboutit pas ce
qu'il souhaite ça se transforme assez
rapidement en une agressivité importante
qui peut faire peur je crois et
d'ailleurs les témoins nous l'ont
souvent dit tout au long de cette
procédure il est écrit par nombre de
personnes de son entourage jusqu'à son
père qui nous déclarait qu'il avait été
menacé de mort c'est dire que monsieur
Dubois avait un ascendant certain sur
ces deux acolytes et qu'effectivement il
a été un petit peu le moteur de toute
cette affaire incontestablement
pour prouver son innocence Philippe
Dubois va présenter un alibi mais le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
celui-ci n'est pas très convaincant
Philippe Dubois atteste que le soir des
faits il devait
être
en train de travailler sur à vider des
containers dans une cité
il a peut-être un alibi pour ce soir là
on va aller vérifier chez son employeur
la seule chose que l'on va prendre c'est
qu'il est allé chez cet employeur qui
lui a fait des retenues de salaire parce
qu'il effectuait jamais son travail il
est allé menacer et puis bizarrement les
bureaux de cet employeur ont pris feu
après la visite et les menaces de
monsieur Dubois
Philippe Dubois aboie affirmé son
innocence les taux se resserre autour de
lui et si les enquêteurs avaient encore
des doutes sur son compte une expertise
scientifique va venir y mettre fin
lors de leur perquisition dans la
résidence des raspinistes souvenez-vous
les policiers avaient trouvé un mégot
par terre intrigué par le fait que ni
Francine ni son fils ne fume le juge
d'instruction va demander l'analyse ADN
de ce mégot
ce mégot de cigarette va être analysé et
le profil génétique qui va apparaître
c'est celui de Philippe Dubois
Philippe Dubois affirme qu'il ne s'est
jamais rendu chez Francine Raspini ce
qui ce qui donne une coloration
intéressante à sa responsabilité dans
cette affaire à 99,9 % l'expertise
scientifique prouve que Philippe Dubois
s'est rendu chez Francine Raspini
cependant elle ne permet pas de savoir
quand à défaut de natation cet ADN ne
signe pas l'implication de celui qui est
identifié par l'ADN à des faits commis à
une date déterminée les policiers le
savent pour comprendre ce qui est arrivé
au raspigny il leur faut maintenant
retrouver le corps des victimes les mois
passent rien évolue l'enquête est au
point mort Philippe Dubois Patrick et
Laurent Gauvin sont maintenant en
détention à la prison de Nice c'est dans
cette promiscuité que va se jouer un
nouveau rebondissement
[Musique]
février 2003 voilà maintenant presque un
an que les trois suspects sont détenus
dans la prison de Nice et la vie en
détention n'est pas facile l'acte est un
acte qui n'est pas un acte triglorieux
et rapidement les portes se ferment
autour d'eux il est peut-être plus
difficile de cantiner à la maison
d'arrêt face aux privations Laurent
Gauvin semble le plus fragile les
gardiens vont remarquer que le jeune
homme est nerveux et qu'il passe une
grande partie de son temps à écrire
serait-il en train de coucher sur le
papier c'est confessions
l'administration pénitentiaire nous
prévient de la découverte de du courrier
qui est très important qui est
fondamental les policiers entrent dans
la cellule et la fouille Laurent Gauvin
les observe et avant qu'il trouve la
lettre il valent leur donner trois
feuilles recto-verso écrite à la main
nous nous sommes procurés cette lettre
le jeune homme y affirme qu'il est à
l'origine du double crime
ce jour je prends la décision d'assumer
mon entière responsabilité dans les
événements survenus le dimanche 10 mars
contre la famille Raspini je savais que
cette famille était riche qu'elle
gardait certainement de l'argent à son
domicile il était prévu de laisser aucun
témoin mais mon père n'était pas au
courant de nos intentions ces personnes
sont mortes et enterrées
Laurent Gauvin va nous dire j'ai
participé à au double meurtre je suis
donc l'un des auteurs je ne vous
donnerai pas le nom des autres et je ne
mets pas en cause du bois je ne veux pas
non plus mettre en cause mon père et je
ne pour l'instant je ne veux pas vous
dire où se trouve les corps que Laurent
Gauvin refuse d'impliquer son père ses
compréhensible pour les policiers mais
pourquoi cherche-t-il à innocenter aussi
Philippe Dubois l'enquête va démontrer
qu'en réalité le jeune homme a rédigé
ses aveux sous l'influence directe de
son acolyte
on apprend par un côté de nu que Laurent
Gauvin a écrit ses aveux a rédigé ses
aveux à partir d'un brouillon et que ce
brouillon a été remis suggéré par
Philippe Dubois du bois pour aller très
bien faire passer des messages à Gauvain
même si c'était pas dans la même belle
dans le même bâtiment ou même de la
maison d'arrêt
du bois avec pouvait terroriser Gauvain
qui n'était pas un voyou
c'était pas du tout le même le même
mental du bois un mental de voyou Dubois
avait une réelle emprise sur Gauvain et
cette emprise est allée au-delà de ces
espérances parce que Gauvain voulait se
prouver à lui-même éprouver à son ami
qu'il admirait qu'il était capable du
pire lui aussi et le pire va se révéler
aux yeux des enquêteurs quelques jours
après car Laurent Gauvin va finalement
accepter de les conduire sur les lieux
du crime
6 mars 2003 à 13h45 les enquêteurs et
Laurent Gauvin quittent la maison
d'arrêt aborde un convoi de la police
judiciaire dans la voiture de tête c'est
le jeune homme qui indique la route à
suivre
nous partons avec Laurent Gauvin et le
juge d'instruction est plusieurs
collègues afin de nous rendre à
l'endroit qui veut bien nous indiquer
une certaine tension règne dans la
voiture les policiers espèrent que loin
de l'influence de Philippe Dubois le
jeune homme va leur livrer enfin la
conclusion de l'affaire à la sortie de
Nice dans le quartier de Saint-Isidore
pas très loin de la cité des moulins
Laurent Gauvin fait arrêter les
enquêteurs dans un virage près d'un
talus
et leur indique le chemin d'un petit
bois
il va nous conduire dans les bois
et va nous dire c'est là tout simplement
la végétation repoussée on n'y croit pas
forcément tout de suite on commence à
donner quelques coups de pioche
il a pas l'air d'être trop sûr
mais on va s'entêter un petit peu il est
là aussi la teste il est devant le
magistrat instructeur
il est froid il sort le peu il est
assidu
ou passion les pelles les pioches nous
étions plusieurs à nous relayer la terre
était difficile dure du pudding avec des
galets avec de la terre
et puis on voyait rien et puis passer 50
cm 60 cm un mètre l'escavation ont
commencé à prendre de la de l'ampleur on
était un petit peu flou sur la largeur
et la profondeur nous laissait un petit
peu circonspect on commence à
s'inquiéter un petit peu pendant deux
bonnes heures les policiers vont creuser
de plus en plus profond
et on va faire un trou de plus un mètre
50 de profondeur sur plus de 2 mètres de
large
et on va commencer à trouver le premier
corps
[Musique]
c'est un morceau de tissu qui va
apparaître en premier ce tissu c'est un
morceau de drap dans lequel se trouve
Marc Raspini
le visage est très difficile à
identifier Marc Raspini et Bayonnais et
ligoté avec du sparadrap
un spectacle insoutenable
[Musique]
faites son décor qui ont été momifiés
ils sont restés dans cette terre
argileuse ce pudding de la région
niçoise si particulier les corps sont
complètement desséchés
[Musique]
et puis sous le corps de Marc tedesh il
y a celui de sa mère
[Musique]
Francine rospini était dessous et son
fils était au-dessus n'avait
l'impression qu'elle le tenait dans ses
bras c'était un moment émouvant et avec
une symbolique vraiment très forte
c'était c'était vraiment sur un plan
émotionnel assez important
tellement important que Laurent Gauvin à
ce moment-là n'a pas voulu regarder le
fond de la fosse
dans les jours qui suivent l'autopsie va
révéler les causes de la mort il
apparaît que Marc Raspini a été tué le
premier il a été semble-t-il
étranglé mais ça n'est peut-être pas ce
qui a causé la mort en tout cas il y a
des traces de strangulation certaines et
l'ossoïde est endommagée et puis des
traces de coup notamment au visage et
sur certaines parties du corps
c'est ensuite sa mère qui a dû affronter
la mort d'une façon particulièrement
atroce
[Musique]
l'un des traces de fracture au niveau de
du péroné du péroné gauche à la des
traces traumatiques également
mais surtout
son décès et estimé à une asphyxie
c'est asphyxie
elle peut avoir deux origines il y a
deux hypothèses qui sont retenues dans
cette affaire la première c'est que
c'est le bâillon qu'il étouffe et la
seconde qui est privilégiée c'est
qu'elle est morte enterrée
il reste une dernière question à
élucider quel est le relais exact de
Philippe Dubois dans le meurtre des
Raspini
Laurent Gauvin affirme qu'il est
totalement innocent et que tandis que
son père restait dans la voiture c'est
un mystérieux troisième homme qui l'a
assisté mais pour les enquêteurs cela
est bien difficile à croire quand on
fait le compte on est sur quelqu'un qui
fait peur qui a de l'ascendance sur vous
qui est proche de vous parce que on ne
va pas faire ce genre de coup avec un
inconnu qu'on n'a pas rencontré de
l'avant veille et puis si possible pour
des raisons pratiques qui est dans votre
entourage c'est plus facile pour
préparer les choses et donc on en vient
forcément à qui Philippe Dubois et on a
beau tourner cette question dans tous
les sens il n'y a que Philippe Dubois
qui peut être ce troisième homme c'est
la conviction des hommes de l'APG de
Nice Dubois à organiser et diriger le
double meurtre des raspinis et voici
comment le projet criminel aurait germé
dans son esprit
décembre 2001
Philippe Dubois s'est installé sur la
colline de Gairaut
il a loué une parcelle à Francine
Raspini mais rapidement leur relation se
sont en venimées
Philippe Dubois avait décidé de louer
des terrains à Madame Raspini puisqu'on
sait que Madame aspigny et son fils
avait un patrimoine très important et
puis peu à peu il va avoir des histoires
avec l'entourage c'est à dire qu'il va
se fâcher avec des voisins pour des
histoires de chiens il va se fâcher avec
le jardinier plus ou moins et puis
surtout il va y avoir une altercation
avec Madame Raspini altercation très
violente et ça c'est du bois qui est
très violent pourquoi parce que Madame
Raspini vient de lui annoncer qu'elle ne
veut plus de lui sur son terrain et
qu'elle le chasse alors va germer cette
probablement cette idée de se venger et
puis aussi de se venger tout en ayant un
profit dans cette affaire et un profit
non négligeable puisqu'il sait que
Madame raspin a de l'argent et que sans
doute cet argent est caché chez elle
Philippe Dubois aurait réussi à
convaincre les govins père et fils
d'être ses complices sans doute contre
la promesse d'une part du magot et trois
mois plus tard les trois hommes auraient
mis leur plan exécution le dimanche 10
mars 2002 en début de soirée en voiture
conduite par Patrick Gauvin va se garer
à proximité dans un endroit reculé et
tranquille sur le canal de Gairaut le
long de ce canal et bien protagoniste
qui connaît bien les lieux comme
Philippe va pouvoir conduire Laurent
jusqu'aux cabanon en évitant les petits
cabanons où il y a des chiens qui
aboient en évitant les voisins qui sont
là le soir et puis on va agresser marque
Raspini mais Marc Raspini va se laisse
pas faire
[Musique]
il va falloir l'étrangler
la mer semble-t-il est couchée ils sont
allés dans la chambre ils l'ont réveillé
donc vous imaginez aisément la panique
de cette femme qui effectivement a vu
arriver ce soir-là dans sa chambre à
coucher des individus cagoulés armés etc
et qui lui demandait où était son magot
il se laisse pas faire rapidement il
faut au minimum la baïonner la ficeler
et puis une fouille sommaire dans le
capharnaüm qui était la demeure de
Madame Raspini trouver une enveloppe
avec de l'argent ça devait pas être
facile comme ça en pleine nuit
manifestement ils ont récupéré le sac à
main avec les chéquiers et des chéquiers
qui ont ensuite certaines formules de ce
chéquier ont été
remplis libellés par du bois et
distribuer à ces deux acolytes on
récupère la voiture de
qui est là sur la propriété on place le
corps de marque au fond ils vont
convaincre cette vieille dame de ce que
son fils a été visité en premier et
qu'ils l'ont emmené à un autre endroit
et que si elle veut le revoir vivant et
si elle veut elle-même avoir la vie
sauve il est important qu'elle les
accompagne sans faire trop d'histoires
et sans crier
et donc on l'a placé dans le véhicule
qui était là véhicule de son fils dans
le coffre duquel se trouvait le corps du
fils mais ça évidemment elle l'ignorait
et la voiture par vers le lieu où elle
doit être
définitivement supprimé le cortège se
serait rendu à Saint-Isidore Francine
aurait été amené dans le sous-bois
frappé et précipité dans la fosse le
cadavre de son fils aurait ensuite été
jeté sur elle et les trois meurtriers
auraient commencé à reboucher la fosse
alors même que la vieille dame respirait
encore
le terrible forfait accompli les
meurtriers auraient rebroussé chemin
avant d'abandonner la Renault 11 de Marc
Raspini dans le parking de l'Arenas
Sly la version des enquêteurs mais c'est
désormais devant la cour d'assises de
Nice que les trois hommes vont devoir
s'expliquer
19 juin 2006 cours d'assis des
Alpes-Maritimes c'est le premier jour
d'audience
lorsque ce process s'ouvre l'attente des
Niçois c'est de cette connaître la
vérité et c'est surtout de l'enjeu c'est
de voir si du bois va craquer ou pas
dès le début Philippe Dubois se montre
directif et autoritaire vis-à-vis de son
co-accusé Laurent Gauvin
on a l'impression que du bois demande
somme les autres accusés de prendre leur
responsabilités et éventuellement de le
mettre en cause ou pas de le mettre en
cause en l'espèce de ne pas le mettre en
cause pour que enfin pour lui son
innocence soit reconnue ce qui se passe
ici est très saisissant parce que c'est
le moment où du bois prend conscience de
la monstruosité de l'affaire et il ne
peut plus la supporter lui-même si vous
voulez il faut absolument qu'il s'en
dégage et il shoute en direction de son
voisin de boxe qui n'est autre que son
ami d'enfance
pendant une pause dans les débats
Laurent Gauvin va faire une surprenante
demande à son avocat il affirme qu'il
souhaite maintenant révéler l'identité
du troisième homme le mystérieux
criminel qui leur est aidé à accomplir
le double meurtre
je demande une suspension de séance
président qui me l'accorde immédiatement
en pensant que la suspension était
motivée par peut-être des révélations
ces révélations il me les fait dans un
premier temps à moi-même
en me disant voilà le troisième homme
n'est autre que Kamel mknini l'ouvrit
agricole de la propriété rapide
une personne qui de prime abord n'était
absolument pas sur la liste des suspects
bien au contraire puisqu'il avait
participé à l'enquête et à l'instruction
permettant de découvrir la vérité devant
la Cour et contre la vie de son avocat
Laurent Gauvin va donc publiquement
accuser le jardinier d'avoir été son
complice et bien évidemment personne ne
le croit mais qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce je sais que ce petit coup de
théâtre pour nous dire ça ça pour ça et
véritablement ça moi en tout cas
personnellement ça m'a choqué et ça m'a
beaucoup agacé je pense que ça n'a pas
été dans le sens de la défense dans
cette atmosphère lourde l'accusation va
s'attacher à démontrer que le crime a
été prémédité il s'avère ainsi que 15
jours avant le meurtre Patrick Gauvin a
acheté des tenues de camouflage dans un
magasin spécialisé un magasin bien connu
des policiers
il va acheter des Bombers des tenues
camouflées noires des tenues de sécurité
et il aura la bonne idée de venir les
acheter en face de la caserne Ovar dans
un magasin qui est fréquenté notamment
par de nombreux policiers et il achètera
ces éléments avec
en laissant son identité ce qui nous
permettra de remonter sur ses achats et
là aussi reconnaîtra avoir lui-même à
acheter ces éléments une dernière
information va faire frémir les jurés
d'après les relais téléphoniques les
meurtriers sont restés moins de deux
heures sur place le soir du meurtre
or les policiers ont mis plus de trois
heures pour creuser la fosse une
conclusion s'impose les trois hommes
avaient commencé à creuser bien
auparavant
la fosse d'enfouissement a été
préalablement creusé
de façon très profonde et très large
cette opération n'a pas été faite le
soir des faits la nuit des fées parce
que matériellement c'était impossible
c'est quelque chose qui a été programmé
prémédité la préméditation éprouvée
c'est donc un double assassinat que le
tribunal doit juger un assassinat
particulièrement horrible comme viendra
le rappeler le procureur quand je me
suis levé pour requérir il me paraissait
évident que je ne pouvais pas requérir
autre chose que la réclusion criminale à
perpétuité compte tenu de l'horreur et
de la barbarie des faits et que
finalement les trois avaient une
parfaite et égalité de responsabilité
dans l'effet qui s'était commis et donc
je ne voyais plus pourquoi à la fin des
débats j'aurais fait un sort particulier
et un peu plus avantageux à l'un par
rapport à l'autre
23 juin 2006 les jurés rendent leur
verdict ils suivent leur réquisitoire du
procureur et condamne Philippe Dubois
Laurent Gauvin et Patrick Gauvin à la
détention à perpétuité pour l'assassinat
de Francine et Marc Raspini les trois
hommes décident de faire appel et en
2008 le verdict sera revu à la baisse
mais il confirmera la culpabilité des
trois hommes Philippe Dubois et Laurent
Gauvin sont condamnés à 28 ans de prison
et Patrick Gauvin Lepère à 25 ans
mes un mystère demeure le magot où est
passé le magot des Raspini le
journaliste Didier chalumeau envient à
douter de son existence
s'il y avait eu ma gauche je pense qu'il
serait pas resté dans le quartier des
Moulins ils auraient à mon avis il
l'aurait dépensé ce qu'ils ont quand
même été assez longtemps après les faits
et vu le profil des personnages je pense
qu'ils auraient flambés qui
souhaiteraient acheter des voitures ils
ont acheté un appartement ils auraient
changer de train de vie et en fait ça a
pas été ça a pas été le cas pour le
procureur au contraire ce magot a bel et
bien existé le magot il a il a existé
incontestablement il a existé parce que
ils étaient riches les raspignies et que
surtout lorsqu'on est allé voir leur
compte bancaire il y avait rien sur leur
compte et l'argent de leur richesse il
était bien quelque part on en est sûr il
y avait des liquidités chez eux on les a
jamais retrouvés je persiste à penser
que ça a été emporté lors de cette
soirée du 10 mars 2002 ce magot que
Francine Raspini conservait chez elle
par crainte du fisc
ce magot qui lui a peut-être coûté la
vie et celle de son fils
tandis qu'il a poussé trois hommes à
commettre le pire
c'est ce qui rend cette affaire d'une
désespérante ce que vous avez à faire
d'un côté comme de l'autre accusation
victime à des gens sans cœur sans aucune
espèce d'affectivité qui ont finalement
subi le un sort qui est dramatique
qui aurait pu être très différent au
fond il s'était intéressé à autre chose
qu'à l'argent